اساليب قمعيه واعدامات متتاليه كانت هي
السلاح الابرز للنظام الايراني لمواجهه
الغضب الشعبي وبعد مرور 4 اشهر من
الاحتجاجات وتنام الاستياء الشعبي بشكل
غير مسبوق تلا شازخم التظاهرات لكن الغضب
في اعلى مستوياته الاحكام القاسيه التي
كانت موجهه ضد المنشقين والاقليات العرقيه
والنساء على وجه التحديد
جعلت بقيه المتظاهرين الايرانيين يخشون من
مواجهه نفس المصير
سلسله الاعدامات لم تكن السبب الوحيد في
كلاش هذه الاحتجاجات الشعبيه فهناك عوامل
اخرى مثل قتل المتظاهرين بالرصاص
والاعتقالات الجماعيه والاعتداء الجسدي
والعنف الجنسي
كلها عوامل اساسيه كان لها دور في انخفاض
المعارضه من الشارع الايراني من جهه
وازدياد الاستياء الشعبي العام من جهه
اخرى
وتحديدا في المناطق الحدوديه التي تهيمن
عليها الاقليات والتي تحملت العب الاكبر
من قمع النظام
وكما يرى مراقبون فان معظم الاشخاص الذين
تزيد اعمارهم عن 25 عاما ابتعدوا عن
المظاهرات
بالاضافه الى الجيل الاكبر سنا منهم
والذين ضلوا الى حد كبير بعيدا عن الشوارع
التي تعمها الاحتجاجات وهو الامر الذي حرم
الحركه الاحتجاجيه الزخم اللازمه لاسقاط
النظام الايراني
وسطى توقعاتهم بان تعود هذه الانتفاضه
مجددا ضد النظام الايراني بسبب عدم قدرته
على معالجه المشاكل الاقتصاديه المتفاقمه
بسبب العقوبات الدوليه المطلوبه عليها
سلطان العيبان العربيه